شكرا راويه شكرا طاهر طبعا العربيه ما
زالت مستمره في هذه التغطيه
لمثول الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب في
المحكمه الفيدراليه في
اذا مازلنا نتابع هذه الصور
المباشره لمغادره الرئيس ترامب هذه
المحكمه
وتابعنا منذ قليل مغادرته وطبعا الانصار
ما زالوا موجودين في
محيط هذه المحكمه وكنا تابعنا ايضا محاوله
اعتقال احد الاشخاص من هؤلاء الانصار اذا
مشاهدينا نحن مستمرون في هذه التغطيه
التاريخيه للرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد
ترامب والذي يواجه عشرات التهم الفيدراليه
المتعلقه باساءه التعامل مع اسرار حكوميه
طبعا في اخطر تحقيق جنائي يهدد انتقلت
وصوله مجددا الى البيت الابيض طبعا ترامب
دفع ببراءته من تهمه اساءه التعامل في
قضيه الوثائق السريه وقال امام محكمه
ميامي انه غير مذنب ولاحقا سمحت المحكمه
لترامب المغادره من دون شروط كما تابعنا
في هذه الصور المباشره اما شبكه سي ان ان
فقالت انه لن يتم فرض كفاله ماليه على
ترامب مقابل السماح له بمغادره المحكمه
واشارت الى انه لن يتم فرض قيود ايضا على
سفر ترامب بعد مثوله امام المحكمه
من جانبها اكدت المتحدثه باسم الرئيس
الامريكي السابق علي انهبا عدم اهتمام
الاشخاص الذين يوجهون اتهامات ترامب
بالحياد ولا بالاجراءات القانونيه الواجبه
او الحمايه المتساويه للقوانين واتهمتهم
في تصريحاتها لشبكه تيانن بالعمل على
ترسيخ نظام سيء للعداله حيث تكون المعامله
الانتقائيه هي القاعده وفق تعبيرها مضيفه
ان المسؤولين عن هذا البلد لا يحبون
امريكا ولا ترامب حسب تعبيرها
مجددا نذهب الى زميلنا امام محكمه
الفيدراليه في ميامي حسين الطاوضح حسين
اهلا بك معنا الاجواء لديك بعد مغادره
الرئيس ترامب هذه المحكمه
[موسيقى]
بالفعل ميسون كان هناك اشكال وقامت الشرطه
باعتقال احد الاشخاص المتظاهرين للمناصريه
ترامب كان هذا اول حادث نشاهده هنا الشرطي
يطلب منا التراجع قليلا اول حادث اعتقال
نشاهدها هنا في الحقيقه كانت كان اليوم
يعني مره بسلام كان هناك عدد كبير من
المناصريه ترامب يحتجون هنا وكان هناك
يحتاجون باجواء احتفاليه
يرفعون اليافطات المؤيده له وطبعا هي في
قطاط تندد
بايدن ولكن
الشرطه كانت متواجده ايضا بكثافه وكان
هناك قلق عباره عنه الشرطه في المؤتمر
صحفي البارحه مع العمده عندما قالت انهم
قلنا نحن وجود احداث عنف ولكن كما قلنا
اليوم مره بسلام لم نشهد احداث عنف هنا
ابدا غالبيه المتظاهرين كما قلنا من
الجمهوريين وهذا امر طبيعي ومنطقي فلوريدا
ولايه تميل للجمهوريين كان هناك اشخاص
اطلب من الولايات من الساحل الغربي ومن
الولايات الشماليه الى هنا
لتاييد ودعم ترامب الان
مغادره ايضا بعد وسائل الاعلام التي حضرت
بكثافه كان هناك تغطيه اعلاميه كبيره لهذا
الحادث هذا الحدث هو اول اول مره يتم
توجيه اتهام
فيدرالي لرئيس سابق وثاني مره
لكن لم تكن المره الاولى في نيويورك تهمه
فيدراليه كانت على مستوى الولايه حيث مثل
امام محكمه في نيويورك هذه اول مره تهمه
فيدراليه سلاح التهام فيدرالي لذلك كان
هناك تغطيه اعلاميه واهتمام اعلامي كبير
محطات محليه امريكيه ومحطات دوليه هذا
الاجر ايضا ستستمر طيله هذا اليوم
ستنتهي مع نهايه هذه المحكمه
من المرجح ان تنتهي مع نهايه هذه المحكمه
بدانا كما قلت لك ميسون نلاحظ مغادره
العديد من وسائل الاعلام مغادره العديد من
المواطنين بعد نسيم الان بعدما غادر ترامب
بعدما تم تلاوه لائحه التهام عليه وقال
بانه غير مذنب الان بدانا نلحظ بان
المناصرين بداوا يغادرون
ما يعتقد من هنا حتى ساعه او ساعتين
ثلاث ساعات ستعود الامور الى طبيعتها ولكن
ما نراه الان من ازدحام هو خروج الناس
كلهم وهذا ما كانت قد حذرت منه شرطه ميامي
من الرقاد يتم العرقله السير بسبب الاعداد
الكبيره التي اتت كان هناك كما قلت تواجد
كبير للجمهوريين من مختلف الاعراق
اللاتينيين وحتى من الامريكيين من اصول
افريقيا
جرى هذا المسؤول داخل المحكمه
ماذا قال ترامب غير انه غير مذنب
يعني كم المده التي استغرقها داخل المحكمه
دخل دخلت رب طبعا كان هناك محاميين قدماء
صباحا اوراق
لتمثيله امام المحكمه كان الى جانبه وكان
معه ايضا احد
مساعديه الذين تم توجيه لهم التهم حتى
المساعد دفع بانه بريء وبانه غير مذنب
المحكمه اخذت سبيل ترامب من دون شرط
طبعا منعته من التواصل مع
الشهود ولكنه يسمح له بالسفر لم تمنعه من
السفر واليوم هو سيغط سيكون هناك سفر
داخلي الى
ولايه جورجيا في الشمال حيث سيلقي خطاب
لمؤيده لانصاره هذا ما نعرفه حتى الان هو
قال انه غير مدن كما قلنا اخلط سبيله من
دون شروط او بالنون دفع كفاله ماليه هذه
المعلومات الاوليه التي وصلتنا لكن طبعا
ستاتي هذه المعلومات تباعا في الساعات
القليله القادمه
ما كانوا يعلقون عليه انصار ترامب عن ماذا
كانوا يتحدثون كيف ينظرون الى هذه المحكمه
ماذا كانوا يقولون
بالنسبه لانصار ترامب الملاحظ يعني الذي
تلمسيه لامس اليد بانهم مقتنعون بانها
مطارده سياسيه بان هذه المحاكمه والمحاكمه
السابقه كل هذه التهم ذات دوافع سياسيه
وبان هناك دوله عميقه وبين ترامب يستطيع
اذا فاز بالانتخابات بان يزيلها ما
يستطونه بالطبقه الفاسده التي تحكم واشنطن
بيش في اشاره الى
الاداره الامريكيه
ولاحظنا ايضا تبنيهم للمصطلحات الاخيره
التي بات ترامب يستخدمها وهي الشيوعيين
والماركسيين واليسريين الذين يعملون على
تدمير الولايات المتحده بشكل منهجي هذا
كانت اعلان لترامب على السوشيال ميديا
لاحظت الكثير من هؤلاء الجمهوريين يتبنون
هذا الفكر الذي يتبنون هذا هذه المصطلحات
يسيرون بما يريده ترامب بانه يظهر
المواجهه بينه وبين وزاره بين القضاء بشكل
عام على انها مواجهه بينه وبين الشيوعيين
هو وامريكا واحد هناك اعتقاد لدى هؤلاء
المناصرين بان تربح صادق بما يقوله هم لا
يهتمون حتى وان عبر البعض منهم على انه
بطريقه تعامله مع الوثائق هو اخطا ولكن هم
يرفضون التهم يقولون هذه التهم يجب ان لا
ترقى الى تهمه التجسس لانه تجسس او بانه
تامر هذا تعامل الخطا ويعتقدون كما يقول
هو ان هناك كيل بمكيالين هناك سياسه
معايير مزدوجه لانه لم يعامل بايضا مثل ما
عمل هو حتى وانه احتفظ بوثائق سريه عندما
كان نائبا للرئيس كذلك بالنسبه لهلاري
كلينسن التي
قضيه البريد الالكتروني والسيرفر التي
التي كانت تستخدمه يقولون لماذا لا يحاكم
هؤلاء ويحاكم ترامب طبعا ازاله العدل كانت
الامريكيه ويقولون بانها مسيسه وبينست
القضاء ويشيرون دائما الى ان لا يتم
معامله جواب ايضا رغم ان ابنه هنتر بايدن
ايضا هناك تهم بانه تقبل رشاوه
ولكن
ايضا نتابع هذه الصور ايضا
يتحدث مع انصاره هناك تجمع متواجد ايضا في
ميامي والرئيس ترامب يتحدث مع الناس ومع
انصاره في هذه الصور التي تصلنا تباعا
نذهب الى لنستمع الى الصوت الطبيعي ومن ثم
نعود
الرئيس
لوقوفك في وجههم في وجه هؤلاء الشيوعيين
الذين منحوا كوبا الى الصين
[موسيقى]
الى النوم
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
اذا مشاهدينا ما زلنا نتابع الرئيس ترامب
مع بعض انصاره في ميامي يلقي التحيه عليهم
ويتحدثون معه
وطبعا يساندونه في هذه اللحظات الصعبه
التي يمر بها الرئيس ترامب من خلال هذه
المحكمه التي مثل امامها لمده تقريبا ربع
ساعه نص ساعه وقال بانه غير مذنب وطبعا
اليوم الاجراءات الامنيه كانت مشدده جدا
في ميامي نستمع اذا كان يتحدث الرئيس
ترامب الان
يشكرونا يشكرهم وايضا هم يعبرون عن حبهم
للرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب
وايضا ياخذون صور تذكاريه مع الرئيس
السابق دونالد ترامب
وطبعا ما زلنا نتابع هذه الصور
المباشره مما ياميل الرئيس ترامب مع بعض
من انصاره ومحبيه اشكرك حتى الان زميلنا
حسين الطاوود اعطيتنا صوره واضحه عن
الاجواء التي كانت بمحيط هذه المحكمه التي
غادرها ترامب منذ قليل ووصل الى هذا
التجمع
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
يعني لا ادري هذا اليوم كان عيد ميلاده
الحقيقي ولكن نتابع
المناصرين الذين ينشدون اغنيه او يتمنون
له ايضا عيد ميلاد سعيد وهو الان ياخذ صور
تذكاريه مع محبيه وانصاره
لدينا بلدا بات فاسدا بلدا يعاني من شح
المياه ولا يوجد فيه الا المشاكل الكثيره
وترون وضع الناس اين باتت احوالهم واين
اتجهت لدينا
الان في حاله
في منعطف النزولي
شكرا لكم
[تصفيق]
يشكر الرئيس ترامب مناصريه وكان تحدث بانه
سيلتقي ايضا بمناصريه وسيكون له ايضا خطاب
معهم الليله
مازال يحيي المناصرين
ومحبيه الذين يلتقي بهم في هذه الاثناء في
ميامي قبل ان ينتقل الى نيوجيرسي حيث ايضا
سيلتقي بمناصريه ويتحدث معهم خلال الساعات
المقبله
وكنا تابعناه عند مغادرته لهذه المحكمه
التي مثل امامها واقر بانه غير مذنب وكانت
المحكمه اخذت سبيله من دون قيود ومن دون
اي شروط او دفع اي كفاله ماليه
ما زالت هذه الصور تاتينا مباشره من ميامي
حيث هناك تجمع
التقى بهم الرئيس ترامب وما زال ايضا يسلم
على محبيه ومناصريه في هذا التجمع ليس
لدينا اي معلومات حول هذا المكان الذي
يتواجد فيه ولكن طبعا في ميامي لانه بعد
قليل جدا من مغادرته للمحكمه التقى بهؤلاء
المناصرين
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
الاصوات تتعالى ويحييون الرئيس ترامب الذي
مثل امام المحكمه اليوم وغادرها منذ قليل
هذه المحكمه التي تعد تاريخيه لاول مره
يتهم رئيس سابق للولايات المتحده
بهذه الاتهامات
الفيدراليه وهي تعتبر سابقه
وهذه الوثائق يعني طبعا هذه التهم كلها
تتعلق بوثائق سريه تعنى بالامن القومي حسب
ما ذكرت وزاره العدل وتهدد الامن القومي
ولكن الرئيس ترامب يعتبر هذه
المحاكمه هي مسيسه
وهي موجوده لعرقله وصوله الى البيت الابيض
في انتخابات 20 24 كما ايضا يرى حقيقه
المشاهدين بعض الجمهوريين يعتبرون بان هذه
القضيه مسيسه بينما الديمقراطيون
يعتبرونها تجسيدا للقانون ولديمقراطيه في
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ولاهميه
القضاء والعداله والقانون في الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه بعض الجمهوريين يعتبرون
بان ما يحصل في هذه المحاكمه هو نهايه
للديمقراطيه في الولايات المتحده حتى
عندما اطلقت هذه الاتهامات في الايام
الماضيه البعض اعتبر بانه يوم اطلاق هذه
الاتهامات بانه يوم حزين للولايات المتحده
الامريكيه طبعا هناك انقسام بالشارع
الامريكي حول مؤيدين بشكل كبير للرئيس
ترامب وبنفس الوقت ايضا معارضين بشكل كبير
للرئيس ترامب دائما الرئيس ترامب كان يثير
الجدل من خلال هذا الانقسام الحاصل في
الولايات المتحده حول شخصه
اذا مازلنا نتابع هذه الصور من ميامي
قبل قليل تبعنا مغادره الرئيس ترامب من
المحكمه ووصل الى تجمع الثقفي بعض محبيه
ومناصريه الذين حيوه وايضا غنوا له وتمنوا
له عيد ميلاد سعيد وما زالوا ايضا
متواجدين على جانب الطرقات حيث يغادر هذه
المحكمه من المرتقب ان يذهب الان الى
نيوجيرسي لانه لديه ايضا خطاب مع مناصريه
هناك نحن نرتقب ماذا ستتضمن كلمته بعد
مثوله امام المحكمه اليوم باقراره بانه
غير مذنب نعود ونذكر بانه المحكمه اخلت
سبيله من دون اي شروط ومن دون اي قيود او
دفع اي كفاله ماليه هناك فرق بين هذه
المحكمه التي مثل امامها اليوم الرئيس
ترامب والمحكمه التي مثل امامها في ابريل
في نيويورك البعض يع بانه لا مقارنه بين
القضيتين اذ ان هذه القضيه اليوم هي جديه
اكثر هي تعنى بالامن القومي وهي لاول مره
يمثل رئيس للولايات المتحده الامريكيه
رئيس سابق او اي رئيس امام هذه الاتهامات
حيث اتهم بانه احتفظ ببعض الوثائق السريه
بعد خروجه من البيت الابيض كما قالوا بانه
عرقل العداله
وايضا هذا تهديد للامن القومي على كل حال
سنذهب الى زميلتنا مديره مكتب العربيه في
واشنطن ناديه بلبيسي ناديه انتهت هذه
انتهى مثول الرئيس ترامب الرئيس السابق
دونالد ترامب امام هذه المحكمه التي تعد
حقيقه تاريخيه وخطيره جدا لانها فيدراليه
هذه المره ماذا لدينا من تفاصيل حول ما
جرى اليوم
اهلا بك ميسون دعيني اولا اضيف لهذه
التغطيه المميزه في الواقع على العربيه
وما ذكرتيه قبل قليل اولا عيد ميلاد
الرئيس هو غدا بالفعل 14 يونيو سيبلغ 77
من العمر وبالتالي ربما مؤيديه وانصار
وارادوا ان يهنئونه اليوم المكان كان في
مطعم قريب من المحكمه
والاعلام الليبرالي قبل قليل انتقد هذه
الصور وقال بان الرئيس سيستخدمها ويوظفها
في حمله الانتخابيه ليظهر دعم مؤيديه له
طبعا انصاري الذين تجمعوا ربما العدد لم
يكن كاف يعني الشرطه كانت تتوقع ربما 5000
لكن لم يصلوا الى هذا العدد على كل
الاحوال
ما رايناه اليوم هو ما كنا نتوقعه وبان
الرئيس قال بانه غير مذنب بانه لن يتم
تحديد تقييد سفر وخارج المتحده وفي الداخل
او دفع مبالغ ماليه اسمحي لي ان اشرح هذه
الحيثيه بالتحديد عاده تطلب من الاشخاص
الذي يتخوف في القضاء بانهم عندما يواجهون
تهم سيقومون بالهروب من البلاد والسفر الى
بلد تالت وعدم العوده لكن نعرف بان الرئيس
ترامب مرشح رئاسي وبالتالي لا خوف عليه
بان يترك البلاد ويريد ان يكون رئيس لهذه
البلاد لذا المحكمه لم تتدخل بالنسبه
لتقييد حركته او سفره او حتى دفع غرامه
ماليه
ايضا عندما دخل الرئيس الى المحكمه نعرف
بان كان معه اقرب محامين له وهناك ايضا
جدل حول عدد المحامين البعض يرى بانه لم
يستطع الرئيس تجنيد محامين بدرجه كافيه
لانه هو دوم يتدخل في هذه القضايا يمكن ان
يتعرضوا ايضا لملاحقات قانونيه والبعض يرى
بانه بعض المحامين المعروفين لا يريدون ان
يربطوا اسمهم باسم الرئيس ترامب حتى اذا
كان هناك قضايا اخرى معروفه مشهوره لاحقا
لا تتاثر سمعتهم بربط اسمهم باسم الرئيس
ترامب
طبعا ما رايناه اليوم في داخل المحكمه هو
مثوله لفتره قصيره جدا لم يتم اخذ الصوره
التقليديه للمتهمين ولم يتم استخدام الحبر
في البصمه استخدمه بطريقه الليزر حتى ايضا
لا يتم استخدامها سياسيا لاحقا
الرئيس لن يقوم بتقديم اي تنازل مع المدعي
العام او مع اي طرف في المحكمه لانه منذ
البدايه الرئيس يتحدى النظام القانوني في
الولايات المتحده ونحن نعرف كما ذكرت بان
هذه المحكمه مختلفه عن المحاكم السابقه
لانها محكمه فيدراليه والان طبيعه التهم
فيها الكثير من الجديه والخطوره لانها
تتعلق بالامن الوطني الامريكي ولان الرئيس
ليس فقط بانه اخذ معه هذه الوثائق السريه
عندما غادر البيت الابيض لكنه رفض ان
يسلمها مره اخرى الى المكان الطبيعي لها
هو ما يسمى بالسجل الوطني المحفوظات
الوطنيه طبعا دفاع ترامب بانه العمليه
مسيسه وبانها احتفظت بهذه السيرفا البريد
الالكتروني والرئيس ترامب لديه وثائق
ايضا كان لديه وثائق وليس بدفاع لانه حتى
لو كان القضاء قد تجاهل هذا يعني ازدواجيه
في المعايير لكن ليست تبرئه من التهم
ومن هنا اعتقد بانه من الان وصاعدا الرئيس
يستمر بالحملات الانتخابيه الليله
بالتحديد عندما يعود الى ملعب الجولف الذي
يملكه في ولايه نيوجيرسي والذي سيقضي فيها
وقتا لانه في الصيف كما تعرفين درجات
الحراره مرتفعه في فلوريدا لن يبقى في
مارلاجو سيبقى في نيوجيرسي
سيلتقي مع الداعمين له ماليا ما يسمى
اي الليله سيكون له خطاب في بدايه هذه
الحفل بدايه الحفل سيتحدث فيه طبعا عن ما
جرى في المحكمه ونستطيع ان نتنبا بما
يقوله الرئيس ترامب ليس لانني على علم
بخطابه لكن لاني اتوقع ما سيقوله لانه بات
معروفا اولا الرئيس يقول بانه ضحيه ضحيه
لنظام هو يعتبره بانه في العديد من
الديمقراطيين سواء كانوا في وزاره العدل
او في المحاكم
ويقول بانه هذه المحاكمه هي فقط لمنعه
وثنيه من الترشح للانتخابات الرئاسيه
وسيقول بانه هذه التهميه غير صحيحه وبانه
نزع السريه عن بعض هذه الوثائق وانه من
حقي من ضمن صلاحياته الرئاسيه وليست
الدستوريه بان يحتفظ ببعض هذه الوثائق
وطبعا سيكون هناك
دفاع عنه في المحكمه وقد تستغرق هذه
المحاكمه اشهر ربما عام لا نعرف لكن البعض
يتوقع ان تكون قبل الانتخابات الرئاسيه
لكن هذا لن يؤثر كثيرا على رئيس ترامب
لانه كما ذكرتي مؤيديه يبقون معه حتى
النهايه بغض النظر لكن المؤيدين هم فقط
30% من الحزبه الجمهوري هذا ليس كافي
للرئيس لان يفوز حتى بتاييد الحزب ربما
يستطيع ان يفوز به تاييد الحزب لكنه ليس
كافيا بالوصول الى البيت الابيض هو بحاجه
لاصوات المستقلين في الولايات المتارجحه
وهذا سيكون صعب جدا في ظل هذا الانقسام
الذي تعيشه الولايات المتحده وشخصيه ترامب
الجدليه والانقسامات التي التي نراها في
البلاد والقضايا القانونيه التي تلاحقه
منذ البدايه طبعا يعني الكل يتوقع بان
يساعد الليله ترامب يعني حتى منذ قليل قال
بانه البلد فاسدا واحوال الناس اصبحت سيئه
داخل الولايات المتحده الامريكيه على كل
حال دائما سنكون ونتابع لكل هذه التطورات
وسنتابع طبعا خطاب ترامب في نيوجيرسي
اشكرك حتى الان من واشنطن مديره مكتب
العربيه ناديه بلبيسي في واشنطن على كل
هذه التوضيحات والشرح المفصل لفهم حقيقه
ما يجري حول محاكمه ترامب
السؤال الان مشاهدينا ما الذي ينتظر ترامب
في حال ادانته بحسب وسائل الاعلام
الامريكيه سيواجه الرئيس الامريكي السابق
ادانه بالسجن لمده تصل الى 22 عاما في
قضيه الوثائق السريه المرتبطه بالبيت
الابيض هذا وقال المدعي العام السابق
ديفيد
يواجه سبعه او تسع سنوات اضافيه في السجن
بسبب عرقله سير العداله في القضيه نفسها
ولهذا هناك فريق قانوني كامل للدفاع عن
الرئيس السابق ترامب لكن عضوا رئيسيا في
هذا الفريق جذب الانتماء الانتباه اكثر من
غيره وهو المحامي تعود بلانش نتابع
[موسيقى]
الجمهوريه السابق عن الولايات
اهلا بكم سيد توم كيف تعلقون على مثول
الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب اليوم في هذه
المحكمه واقراره بانه غير مذنب
اعتقد ان البلاد منقسمه حول هذا الموضوع
علينا ان نتذكر ان جاكس مثل
المحقق الخاص في هذه القضيه كان
مقربا من الحزب الديمقراطي وكان قد ساهم
بشده في حمله بايدن لكنه قد تم اقالته من
قبل المحكمه العليا في السابق في احدى
القضايا ما حدث ان بايدن هو لديه بعض
المستندات السريه ولم يتحدث احد عنها هو
كذلك الحال بالنسبه لكلينتون التي دمرت
الاف المعلومات من رسائل الكترونيه دون
معرفه عدم لسريه دون معرفه سريتها من
عدمها ولم يتهم احد بانتهاك تلك القوانين
ولدينا ايضا ابن بايدن الذي يتلقم ملايين
الدولارات ولا يبدو ان اي احد ين بث ببنت
شفا لذا في اعداد كبيره من الامريكيين ولا
سيما الجمهوريين ينظرون الى القضاء من
منظور مختلف لا اعتقد في هذه المرحله ان
دونالد ترامب قد اتعرض الى اي
تهديد قد يدينه قد تكون
وقد يكون هناك بعض الامور التي يجب ان
ننظر اليها رغم معرفتها انهما من رئيس
امريكي سابقا تم توجيه اللوائح الاتهام
هذه كلها له
بالنسبه لهذه المحاكمه نفهم من حديثك الان
بانكم تعتبرون بان ما يجري هو تسييس لهذه
القضيه وليس اقرارا للقانون في الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه والعداله
نعم هذا قد قسم البلاد
وجعلها
تكون بين
معرفه اذا ما كان مذنبا من عدمه
البعض يعتبر بانه ما يجري هو نهايه
للديمقراطيه في الولايات المتحده اليس
هناك من مبالغه في هذا التوصيف
اعتقد انها مبالغه الامر يجب ان يتضح
عن ما قد تحمل هذه القضيه فان الادعاء
العام
سوف يعمل على اجراء محاكمه عادله
قد نكون بحاجه الى عدد اكبر من هيئه
المحلفين الذين يقرون بذنبه بالاجماع لذا
المحاكمه لا بد انها سوف تكون عادله ومن
غير المنصف ان نتحدث عن انهاء الديمقراطيه
في البلاد
حد ما يجري مع
الرئيس وهذه التهم وفي هذا التوقيت هو
موجه لابعاده عن المشهد السياسي كما يصف
انصاره
حقيقيه لان الادعاء لان المدعى العام قد
ساهم مع خصمه
بصوره واضحه وكذلك مقرب من الرئيس السابق
اوباما
ولا يبدو بان هناك
الا ادله واضحه تظهر عن مدى التعاطف بين
المدعي العام
ومع الحزب الديمقراطي لانه حتى لانه لم
ينظر في كافه القضايا المتعلقه باي رئيس
بالرئيسي بايدن او فيما يتعلق بملف ابنه
هنتر بايدن
قد تكون هذه القضيه تحمل فتره طويله
وكنا قد سمعنا ندائين في الاسبوع الماضي
احد احدهما من بايدن
ومن بعض انصاره الذين كانوا قد تحدثوا عن
عدم صلاتهم بهذه القضيه لكن الكل قد اشار
بان الرئيس بايدن قد عمل على اتلاف كافه
الوثائق السريه الموجوده لدي لماذا لم
يتعاون مع المؤسسات الامنيه والفدراليه
حتى اعتبر بانه معرقلا بانه معرقل لهذه او
للعداله
يعني
ان تشرحي هذا الامر لدون الترامب لا اعلم
لماذا قام بهذا الامر البعض قد يحاجج بانه
قد يكون خطا من قبله ما كان يجدر ان يحدث
هذا الامر لكن
لكن ارى بان ثمه توجه متعمد تجاهها الرئيس
ترامب لان بايدن يحتوي يمتلكه اكثر من
مجموعه من المستندات السريه الموجوده في
اماكن مختلفه
وبمجرد اكتشافها كان قد اكتشف بانه
بانها كانت بحيازته لسنوات طويله
وانا اؤمن بنظام العدلي المنصف الولايات
المتحده حيث سوف يكون هناك محاكمه معادله
ولكل شخص ان ينال نصيبه اذا ما استطاع
الفوز في هذه المحاكمه
فسوف يكون الديمقراطيون قد خلقوا لانفسهم
مصيبه
لماذا
لانه يبدو
بان هناك انفاذ منطقه للقانون بحق بعض
الاشخاص من خلال وجود المدعي العام
الديمقراطي الذي وجهتها من جنائيه ضد
الرئيس ترامب هو هذا وهذا الامر لا يطال
مواطنا عاديا يقوموا بالاحتفاظ ببعضها
المواد السريه
الرئيس بايدن بالمقابل لديه نفس المشكله
قد تكون لديه نفس اعداد المستندات لكن
بدرجه اقل لكن ارى ان انفاذ القانون يتم
بصوره الانتقائيه على انه قد تلقى
ملايين الدولارات مما يبدو من دول مثل
روسيا والصين من خلال حسابات في الخارج
وزاره العدل على درايه بذلك وكانت تلتزم
الصمت اجزاء الامر لفتره طويله ولم تتصرف
بنفس الطريقه التي توجهت بها
لصيد الترامب والناس ينظرون الى هذا الامر
ويدفعون ويتساءلون اين العداله لماذا لم
يطبق الامر نفسه مع ترامب ومع ابنه هو
خاصه بان الامر يبعث على مخاوف لكن مع ذلك
سوف يحصل على على محاكمه عادله
حضرتك تحدث عن محاكمه عادله ولكن بنفس
الوقت من خلال حديثك نفهم بان هناك تسييس
بان هناك انتقائيه بالنسبه للقضايا ذكرت
الرئيس بايدن ذكرت
ايضا هيلاري كلينتون وموضوع الايميل
لهلاري كلينتن
اين يمكن ان نرى بان هناك عداله وهناك
انتقائيه بالنسبه للمحاكمات
ولا يعلم اذا ما كانت قد تصرفت وزاره
العدل بطريقه صحيحه
لكن مع ذلك لابد من تقديم محاكمه عادله
للوقوف على كافه الاحكام الجنائيه
للمرشح الاوفر حظا بين الجمهوريه هذا هذه
الاسئله التي يجب ان تتم الاجابه عليها
بانه لا يجب ان نضع الحمله الانتخابيه في
هذه
العقبات في في ظل كل الاحداث التي تعيشها
البلاد
الجمهوريه السابقه عن الولايات
من واشنطن ايضا ينضم اليه الان دكتور في
القانون الدولي والخبيث الشؤون الامريكيه
دكتور ناصر فياض دكتور ناصر اهلا بكم معنا
حضرتك قانوني هل يمكن ان تعطينا شرحا
وتفصيلا لما حصل اليوم ولماذا هذه المحكمه
اليوم هي جديه واخطر بكثير مما حصل في
نيويورك في ابريل الماضي
نعم يعني ببساطه تم الادعاء على المواطن
دونالد ترامب
وقد ثقه الى المحكمه
كمتهم
يعني خرج من هناك وقد عين له ضابط مراقب
عليه ان يتعامل معه كلما خرج من المنطقه
وهذا يعني بشكل
من الناحيه الشكليه يطبق عليه القانون هو
الان متهم هو مدعى عليه وله شريك مدى عليه
ايضا
طب ماذا نفهم بانه اخلي سبيله من دون اي
شروط من دون اي قيود من دون دفع اي كفاله
ماليه
طبعا يعني هذا شيء طبيعي ليس كل المدعى
عليهم عليهم ان يدفعوا كفاله ماديه يقيم
القاضي اذا كان هذا الشخص
يعني هناك ريبه بانه لن يعود الى المحكمه
الرئيس السابق ترامب هو رئيس للدوله سابق
وهو مرشح او هو يعني لا يخاف ان ان يغادر
ولا ياتي الى المحكمه او يغادر البلاد
لذلك هذا شيء طبيعي هو يعطى لي مواطنين
اخرين
اقل اهميه بكثير من الرئيس ترامب المهم في
هذه القضيه انها قضيه قد تكون يعني من
اكبر القضايا التي تهدد الرئيس ترامبليون
فهو يرقص على يعني على حافه الهاويه رقصه
الموت لان البعض يعتبر بانه هذه هذه
المحكمه لن تؤثر على وصول الرئيس ترامب
الى البيت الابيض قانونيا
طبعا من الناحيه القانونيه الدستوريه حتى
اذا كان احدهم محكوما وكان حتى في السجن
يستطيع ان يترشح لمنصب رئيس الولايات
المتحده ويستطيع ان يفوز هذا موضوع اخر
ولكن انا اعتقد ان من الناحيه القانونيه
هذا الموضوع جدي جدا
وفي حال يعني ادانته
ستؤدي به الى سجن طويل الامد لعشرات
السنين اما من الناحيه السياسيه فهذا
الموضوع سيؤثر عليه سياسيا ايضا كثيرا
وخاصه نحن دخلنا في خضم الحمله الانتخابيه
ناصر لنكن ايضا منصفين للترامب حتى الان
هو يتصدر باستطلاعات الراي اصوات
الجمهوريين
نعم بس خلينا نكون يعني كمان واقعيين في
موضوع الانتخابات الرئيس ترامب لديه قاعده
صلبه وقاعده كبيره مع العلم انه لم تعد
بنفس الحجم الذي كانت فيه سابقا ولكن
لنقول ان حتى الان لديه مثلا حوالي 30
34% من الاصوات هذه لا تكفيه حتى لان يفوز
بترشيح الحزب الجمهوري وحتى لو افترضنا
انه ربح ترشيح الحزب الجمهوري فهو سيخسر
في النهايه ضد الديمقراطيين لان في
الانتخابات هناك الكثير من الجمهوريين غير
راضيين جمهوريين الذين يدفعون ضرائبهم
جمهورين الذين يطبقون القانون وهم مستاءون
جدا من طريق التعامل الرئيس مع القانون
وهو دائما يحاول ان يكون فوق القانون
ومتميز عن
غيرهون اذا جعل ترامب مرشحهم
انا اعتقد ان الجمهوريين الان هم في مازق
كبير جدا لانه من ناحيه كما ترين يعني حتى
الان الكثير من المرشحين الجمهوريين
يخافون ان يعني لحد اليوم ان يواجه الرئيس
ترامب او ينتقدوه بشكل كبير خوفا على هذه
الكتله التي مازال يتمتع فيها وهذا طبعا
خاطئ ولكن من ناحيه اخرى حتى لو فاز كما
ذكرت يعني لن يفوز باصوات المستقلين لن
يفوز باصوات
الجمهوريين الموجودين في الوسط وطبعا يعني
الديمقراطيين لديهم كتله تعتبر يعني
تقريبا نصف
الناخبين من خلال متابعتك لكل حيثيات من
هذه المحكمه الى اي حد وزاره العدل
دوافعها قانونيه وليست سياسيه لانه الكل
يتهم خطا الجمهوريين يعني والرئيس ترامب
بانه وهو صعد كثيرا بوجه وزاره العدل بان
ما تقوم به هو مسيس ولا يموت للقانون بصله
لنبدا من سنتين لحد اليوم يعني حاول
الارشيف اولا ان يعني يطلب من الرئيس
ترامب ان يسترد هذه الملفات رفض الرئيس
ترامب هذا الموضوع حاول اكثر من مره يعني
حاولت الاداره اكثر من مره ان تطلبها
بالطرق السلميه حاولوا ان يتكلموا معه عبر
محاميه وهناك اليوم ادله دامره عبر يعني
تسجيلات وعبر اناس الذين
يعني ادلوا بشهاداتهم ان الرئيس ترامب
حاول اخفاء هذه
الوثائق وهذا شيء خطير جدا لبن ايضا
الرئيس ترامب خلال كل هذه الفتره
شارك ناس كثيرون ليس لديهم السريه في هذه
الوثائق والتي تعتبر يعني
خطر على الامن القومي المنطق لماذا يحتفظ
الرئيس ترامب بهذه الوثائق ما هي دوافعه
وهو يعرف بانها ستسبب له المشاكل ومن
الممكن ايضا ان تسبب له محاكمه
يعني كما قال لك يعني النائب السابق عليك
اتحدث عن دوافع احتفاظ بهذه الوثائق
الرئيس ترامب يتصرف كالطفل هذه لعبتي ولن
اتخلى عنها مع الاسف الرئيس ترامب يعتقد
انه فوق القانون يعتقد ان لديه كتله
متراصه كبيره جدا ستحميه
مهما فعل وهذا خطا الرئيس ترامبو ولذلك
اقول انه يرقص على حافه الهواء اليوم
والكثير من المحامون لا يريدون ان
يمثلوه لان الكثير منهم الان يواجه يعني
محاكمات والكثير منهم قد واجه محاكمات
ودخل السجن بسبب الرئيس ترامب لذلك يعني
هذا خطا الرئيس ترامب الكبير والذي ما زال
مصر عليه هو يعتقد انه يستطيع ان يفعل ما
يريد
ولن يدينه احد يعني طبعا لديه بعض الحق في
هذا الموضوع لانه مثلا في هذه المحاكمه
هناك
سيكون مجمع محلفين وهؤلاء عليهم كلهم
ان يدينوه بما لا يقبل الشك وانت تعرفينه
ايضا الرئيس بايدن بالنسبه للبريد
الالكتروني
لهلاري كلينتن لماذا لم نجد وزاره العدل
متحمسه لهذه القضايا كما وجدناها مع
الرئيس ترامب
يعني هذا ليس صحيحا لانه اولا بما يخص
هلري اولا انت تعرفين ان الحمله
الانتخابيه للرئيس ترامب كانت لاكور اب
اقبضوا عليها اسجنوها وكل الناس كما تردد
من بعده
والاف بي اي يعني لم تقف على الحياد وكان
لديه اربع سنين ومنهم السنتان الاولتان
على الاقل وظف الرئيس ترامب كل الجهاز
القضائي في الادعاء العامل في ديرالي
لمحاوله ادانه هيلر
اما بالنسبه للرئيس بايدن فطبعا لقد وجدت
عنده بعض الملفات السريه وليس هو الوحيد
ولكن هناك فرق كبير بين ان تكون فعلت هذا
الموضوع عن سهو واعترفت في هذا الموضوع او
كنت مصر ان تخفي هذه الادعاءات اسرار
الرئيس ترامبو واخفاؤه هذه الوثائق هي
المشكله الاساسيه وليست الاحتفاظ بحد هو
لانه كان عن سوء نيه الرؤساء يعني
يحتفظون بكثير من الملفات بعض الاحيان لا
يعرفون انها سريه او يعتقدون ان جهازهم
ارجعها الى الارشيف او الى البيت الابيض
ويعني الرئيس لديه الكثير الكثير من
المشاغل وبعض الاحيان قد تكون هناك هفوات
ولكن الفرق ان تكون تتعامل في هذا الموضوع
عن حسن النيه او سوء نيه عندما وجه الرئيس
بايدن في هذا الموضوع قال انا تحت القانون
وعين يعني وطلب من الادعاء ان يدقق في هذا
الموضوع
تبقى معي لنتابع ايضا بعض الاخبار ومن ثم
اعود اليك اذا مشاهدينا رغم كثره التهم
ضده لا يزال الرئيس الامريكي السابق
دونالد ترامب يتصدر استطلاع الراي على
غريمه
وبقيت منافسيه الجمهوريين حيث سجل ترامب
دعما مهيمنا بنسبه 61% من الناخبين
الجمهوريين مقارنه بثلاثه
شبكه
على نسبه 4% لكل منهما بينما حصل الاخرون
في السباق المزدحم على ارقام احديه اقل من
ذلك
متاعب ترامب القانونيه تتجاوز ملف الوثائق
السريه فالرئيس السابق يواجه محاكمه في
منهات بولايه نيويورك لاتهامه بشراء صمت
الممثله ستورميدان قبل انتخابات 2016 في
مايو الماضي قضت محكمه في منهات بتغريم
الرئيس السابق مبلغ خمسه ملايين دولار في
الدعوه المدنيه التي رفعتها عليه الكاتبه
اي جين كارول بتهمه الاعتداء الجنسي
والتشهير وطالب ترام استعاده المحاكمه وفي
ولايه جورجيا يواجه ترامب احتمال ان توجه
له فاني ويليس المدعيه العامه لمقاطعه
فولتون اتهامات بدعوى محاوله العمل على
الغاء نتائج انتخابات الولايه لعام 2020
بالعوده الى نيويورك سيمثل ترامب للمحاكمه
في اكتوبر المقبل بتهمه الاحتيال الضريبي
لمؤسسه ترامب كما تجري وزاره العدل تحقيقا
ربما يقود لتوجيه اتهامات الى ترامب تشمل
اتهامه بالتحريض على اقتحام الكونجرس عام
دكتور صياد لديس 30 ثانيه ترامب يتعهد
بتعيين مده عن خاص للتحقيق مع
الرئيس
يعني من حقه اذا كان رئيسا يفعل هذا
الموضوع اذا كان هناك ايتهم تستحق ولكن
هذه هذا اصبح تشفي وكيديه انا لا اعتقد ان
القانون في الولائم يعني اجزم القانون لا
يعمل بهذا الشكل في الولايات المتحده انا
اعتقد ان الرئيس السابق ترامب لديها
الكثير من المتاعب الشخصيه التي عليه ان
يعني يحلها الان قبل ان يفكر
بالانتخابات
الشؤون الامريكيه دكتور ناصر فياض اشكرك
وط تتابع هذه الصور المباشره لتحرك طائره
الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب حيث يتوجه الى
نيوجيرسي
لطبعا يلتقي بمناصريه
ومحبي اشكر لكم في المتابعه في امان الله
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات